Ghana's local rice revolution takes
viewers through the thriving landscapes
of rice farms across the country,
highlighting the dynamic innovations and
success stories emerging in the
industry. The documentary showcases the
important roles played by young farmers
and processes while emphasizing the
significance of local rice production
for Ghana's economy by exploring various
stages of the rice value chain and
promoting local
consumption. This film encourages deeper
engagement in the country's agricultural
sector. The West African country's
fertile land holds the promise of
feeding the nation. Today we dive into
the stories of resilience, innovation,
and national pride shaping the rice
industry. We took a trip to one of the
popular places known for rice
production. We caught up with a young
farmer whose experience started on a
family land in 2010. I'm in the person
of Emanuel from
Asetary. Currently we are on the KIS
project that's irrigation scheme project
but me managing my own started from
2020. So managing my own farm is just 5
years now. Yeah. Initially I wasn't
having the intention to become a rice
farmer.
Uh let me say as at now farming
activities is generating a lot of money.
So I have decided to keep in that side.
Initially I I have the intention to
become a bank accountant. Yeah. Because
I have a degree in accountant. Yeah. I
know mainly to become a rice
farmer. Immano shared insights on the
impact of technology and investments in
enhancing livelihoods and creating
employment opportunities in his
community. When we started, you know, uh
we control is done manually like you go
and hire people yourself, you enter into
the right farm and be putting the weeds
yourself. But as time goes on they they
brought some chemical that's selective
herbicide that when you see the weeds
when you spray all will go. So it's
making the work to become easy and pling
to first you hire people to come and dig
it with normal hole. But now due to
technology we have machines that they do
all the plowing which make the work to
become easier. So now if you just have
the startup capital the farming will be
very easy for you. Um the packaging let
me start from the patty care. Yeah we
dry the patty and we blow the
chs then we we weigh them we weigh them
90k that's one bag and milling then we
move to the milling center where they
mail the right or the dehask. Okay. The
milling side the packaging is done per
um the customer requisition. Yeah. But
ideally you package them 5 kg, 10 kg, 25
kg and 50 kg. That's the maximum the 50
kg. Normally it's the the farmers who
convey the patty the wet patty to the
mailing center to process. Then after
that if the farmer said oh okay let me
sell it with the husk for any a third
party to process it. Fine. We have
people who buy with a patty the patty
like that and they process it per the
way they they like it.
Rice production in Ghana has evolved um
and mostly as you mentioned previously
rice production had um stones and it
wasn't
well gra I mean the it wasn't well
graded and also didn't have that kind of
polishing that uh the market demanded.
However, um, new age of limited
currently through our M foods brand, we
beyond production, our farmers farm and
gets good yields. Now when the farmers
get good nutrition, then the patty rice
is well filled and obviously the
nutrition becomes better. Now we have um
a state of the arts melee facility where
we mail hall with stone then we do color
separation or more like color sortter
where we sort out then on white rice
from the lot then we grade we grade on
to long
grain 75% broken 50% broken so now
because we have now graduated we can now
be able to base the different segments
of the market. Some individuals want
long grain. So we sell a premium a long
grain rice to them. Some also want the
bin maybe for
um for other processing into uh p brown
or the rest. For them we sell the
brooking to them as well. Then we also
have the rice brand which animal farmers
are also using as part of their their
feed composition and feed formulation.
So I believe because of we are in a
global village. So we are taking
technologies not only from Ghana but
technologies from across the world as
well and the state of the arts machiner
that we have indeed um is can be able to
give us that right can be able to
compete with any other imported rice.
They also mentioned branding. So every
long green rice is well branded h and
it's because we are growing and then we
decided to now meet the demand of the
farmer and demand of the consumer which
is they looking for well branded
packages and that's where our market and
research have also led us into having
heavily having the arguably the best
branding or packaging in the country.
The labeling is done at different site
and you bring the sacks with the labels
then you come and do the packaging here.
We have people who do the labeling per
what you want them to put on the sack.
Yeah. So they do the labeling they bring
the sack here then they package then
kilo 5 kg and the rest and they sew them
they they seal them there indirect way
of employment to the other committee
members. Uh we have printers those who
do the printing and we have the factory
who uh um do the sack a transparent one
While the coid9 pandemic posed
challenges, it also sparked innovation
in the food industry, attracting
investors who saw potential for
long-term growth. I'm Alex, a factory
manager for Max Industries Limited. The
mats industries is in currently a steady
year of fishes and it's into providing
dry and milling services for uh farmers
right I think uh considering cover you
realize that during that time food the
food and beverage industries became very
very important when everybody was I
think in lockdown they were allowed to
operate and all that he realized that it
dawned on the CEO that no you will have
to put this in place to also help the
country in terms of uh this disaster. So
it was doing that he gain inspiration to
come out with the opmax industries right
I think uh local rice has come a long
way uh born with the days that we used
to have stones and all these things in
local rice and now we have proof seed
method of growing and I mean process it
we are using state of biat dry and the
milling composite meal so currently we
have a 30 metric tier which uses as as a
floor is to grind the rice. Then we have
a capacity of about 100 tons melon rice
that uh processes the rice the dried
rice. So we have from the melon side we
have the pre- cleaner which cleans the
patty rice as the name implies it leans
the patty rice frees it from this uh
debris chaff and all that. Then he
passes it on to the the stoner which
takes stones, clay pebbles, other solid
materials from the rice. Know when
you're harvesting rice, you can pick up
clay pebbles because you go, stones and
other foreign materials, solid foreign
materials. The diston takes the house.
So from there we have the ma that is
what the husk the rice. It takes the hus
of the rice from the kennel and from
there spalled onto the separator. He
separate the hacks rice from the ketta
from the passes it on to the polisher.
We have the three polishes. We have the
primary polisher, the secondary and then
the chair polisher. Now the primary
polisher will first take the first coat
of the brand of it. Secondary one will
continue polishing to make it a bit
whiter and then it is passed onto the
grader. From the grading machine it
sorts the rice into different grades.
That's the long gray, the pera
grid halfb broken and then the very fine
broke. So now the grater sends the long
gray to the water polisher. The dust
polisher using mist the dust polisher
using mist like with me have liquid
polish polish. That's that's the purpose
of the wonder polisher. And from there
it sends it to the laser color. It takes
multiol base from the uh the polished
grains because you are not interested in
those multiolent gears and then from
there it is part onto the and bag unit.
So based on the best you are being for
that period they set it to the whiskey
which is electronic and from there it is
back and please don't h one significant
hurdle needs to be addressed for the
industry to achieve sustained growth and
uh one of the challenges local rice
producers face is they don't really have
good distribution channels. They are not
all over. So when it happens like that,
yes, uh there's a little downtime with
respect to processing or receiving raw
materials
from clients. Nevertheless, we sometimes
do receive them. However, we are not
able to process for them. The reason
being that they are not having any
demand for your side. You know, this
packaging, you have to wait for you to
get customers before you package. If you
package it and you put it down maybe and
you don't get customers to buy it and
it's there for a longer time
and this uh maze w can enter which will
decrease the quality. So you have to
wait for you to get customers before you
you you package.
Every business has its own ch every
business has it own challenges and angel
business um is not alien to that.
Um as a company we've also have our own
fair share of uh issues. Key among the
challenges we have faced as a company is
um the rates of uh interest on credit or
capital or bank loans. Um we actually in
a market we in global village we are
competing uh with a market where the
agricultural sector are getting loans as
single niggets. Unfortunately in in
Ghana loans are in excess of 20s and
30%. Where in very difficult for
um agricultural business to be able to
pick such facilities and be able to
produce to compete with those who are
coming with a single digit interest rate
financing. The second issue is also uh
with
insurance when the way we have car
insurance, home insurance, agricultural
insurance is still in it. There are some
interventions with Ghana agricultural
insurance pool which is no more in
existence. We know some few private
entities are also doing some insurance
for agricultural businesses. uh there's
a need for us to have I call aggreate
aggreate insurance as a big concern
where we provide insurance to cover a
lot of the I mean the activities along
the value chain especially for an agri
business sector where we are fully
relying on rainfed or rain for
agriculture it is because we don't have
enough irrigation supports neither we
have there enough resources to be able
to go in for proper irrig irrigation
facilities to help with our production.
So we rely on God to leave us and that
is also one of the risk factors. So when
we have credits which is sorted out at
very low rates and we have insurance
that will provide that level of or layer
of support for farmers or for businesses
then we believe that we are on road of
drisking agriculture uh in a long short
long term by sharing knowledge and
expertise industry players are
empowering young people to become
innovative entrepreneurs.
Yes. So the opportunities for young uh
individuals um the 72 that I mentioned
it's interesting to know that we are we
are all young
people. I think the the the highest band
of age will be just the the first the
early part of 40 and we have a majority
of the youth being under 40. So yes
there there are opportunities for young
individuals who have the who have the
the capacity to be able to join our
growing and our growing force. Uh
additionally individuals who might also
want to farm there's opportunity for
them as well. Uh outgoers we we have our
production hub or production arm called
Tigaba. Tik
T and out grower social enterprise for
out grower companies out grower farmers
who might want to farm h they can be
able to reach out to taban and tab can
be able to help them out there other
individuals who are also not green
fingered I mean they don't want to do
the agree but they want to do agre we
have a we have a product as well for
them and they can come on board we can
always see our best they can be able to
benefit from agricultural space we also
have the new age economy which is our
newest kid of the block where we are
going to provide trainings
uh for individuals uh some for free and
those who might want in-depth analysis
or in-depth appreciation can also come
on board our master class where we can
be able to help them set up uh the test
we are young individuals we've been able
to achieve it and we know we can be able
to um get to a lot of young individuals
who have interest in agriculture to also
come on board one of the major giants in
the
uh Rice value chain which is aok thing
they started I happened to see their
humble beginning they started and now
they are very they being a client of
ours and we went through taking thing
with them and then as now I can say that
they are producing one of the best
quality of prepar rice you can you can
have in in Ghana. We try our best to
make our doors open for students. Abuk
is behind the brand of Nar. They mostly
deal with some of these young of
students. They sometimes bring them here
have a look at whatever is going on
here. When they come out those are
always we take them through the
processes. We take them through and they
see the final product. They appreciate
it. Yeah. So as a company uh we
commenced 5 years ago with uh barely 10
staff. uh currently we have
72 individuals who we have employed
there and 50% of them being female. Now
this 72 are on new ages or in the
group's payroll. Then in terms of uh
support we have tagged or directly
supported six over 16,000 farmers who by
extension have also reached out to over
60,000 individuals who have also been
engaged along these value chains that
we've been undertaking. When it comes to
tonnage of of rice, we have contributed
every year on year we produce this year
we intend to produce 10,000 metric ton
of of rice on the market. Uh last year
with this just barely 4,000 metro ton of
rice. This year 10,000 of rice on the
market and going forward we are planning
on doing exceeding it in our next
production years. When it comes to rice,
it is a very important crop in Ghana at
the moment. It it didn't used to be. Uh
but consistently as we urbanize, our
eating patterns change. We always want
something convenient to eat. So rice has
become a convenient food for the
Ghanaian population. And we are over 50%
urbanized.
So if you look at the grains when it
comes to our food, maize is number one.
We actually need to produce about 6
million metric tons of maze every year
if we can meet our needs. In fact, over
6 million metric tons because beyond
what we eat for bank, cocoa, et and kink
and all those things. You also need maze
to process all those processed foods by
the big manufacturers like uni liver and
all those companies. And then you need
maze as a main component in animal feed,
especially poultry feed. The poultry
feed usually would have about 60 to
70% maze making the bulk of the food. So
maze is very important. Then comes rice.
Rice has gradually grown to be number
two when it comes to the grains and
cereals that we eat a lot in the in the
country. And we import over 50% of the
rice we we we need. And rice is also
labor intensive, capital intensive and
land intensive. For example, if you have
a hectar of land, your average yield is
5 tons for rice. Your average yield is 5
tons for rice for a hectar of rice. Uh
if I should give you an example, if you
have the same hectare of rice, you can
get over 20 tons of tomatoes or pepper.
and tomatoes and pepper are higher value
crops than rice. So if you look at
rice is become very
important. The return on investment is
not that great and it requires a lot of
resources. Land,
irrigation, water and inputs. Your
average acre of rice would take about
four bags of
fertilizer. So it's a lot of work. Now
what we can do to get the best out of
rice is to apply industrial ecology
principles in the rise value chain. In
fact not just the rise value chain you
can apply industrial ecology principles
in every other value chain where one you
try to be as efficient as possible in
the production your water use your
material use input land use. Two, you
apply the principle of consistency where
the inputs that go into that
system generates products and byproducts
which become inputs within the same
system or another system for growth. Now
on the rice husk we can also um add rice
husk and other organic materials to
generate energy bio gas. So if you have
rice husk plus poulry manure um cow dang
even plantain stems and all those things
any form of organic material you can um
mix them up um for for for for biogas
generation. So there's a lot of
opportunity there. I know a company a
startup in Tamil that uses rice rice has
to make BS like this you see on this
table and like what we've used for the
partitioning behind me for furniture and
if you are producing so much for example
if you have 3 million tons of patty rice
and about a million of that is going to
end up as rice husk that's a million
tons of rice husk that we can use to
make MDN walls for furniture for
construction for ceilings for all sorts
of things that will cut down uh import
bill on importing some of these things.
So rice presents a very great
opportunity going forward. The state
needs to invest in or support farmers to
get a lot of irrigation because rice
drinks a lot of water and um and also
support with mechanization
um land preparation and harvesting. If
you have mechanized harvesting you
actually get better returns. Sometimes
harvesting manually you lose a lot of
the patty but if you have mechanized
harvesting you reduce your post harvest
losses. And another important element
are dryers. If we have dryers in the key
rice production areas rice farmers can
actually dry their patty. Once they
finish drying their patty they can store
and even wait for a better market to
sell. The value chain from farm to
market holds the backbone of Ghana's
rice production. technological
advancements are boosting efficiency and
profitability and offer other business
opportunities.
So how do we approach that? Once you
farm rice and the rice stock grows, what
you take out of of that is the grain
which is the patty rice. Now the stock,
what opportunities are there to use the
rice stock? There are thousand1
opportunities for rice stock. Aside them
being composted and to return nutrients
back into the soil, you can use them for
all sorts of things in the fashion
industry. For mats, for a lot of
different things in the fashion
industry, you can use them in
upholstery. You can process them and
pack them in upholstery. You can use
them in different different forms. So we
need to start thinking about how we can
harvest those things. In Ghana, usually
once the harvester comes to harvest to
cut uh and and get the patty uh will
usually set fire to the to the stalks on
the farm. That's one of the easiest ways
to clear them and repair land for the
next season. That also introduces a lot
of greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
So one of the things we can do is to
strategically also get machines that can
help us. We don't even need machines. We
have a lot of people who need work. Once
we are adding value to the right stock
and creating a product that returns
capital value, we can engage a lot of
people to do that work. That's one. And
then when it comes to the rice patty
itself, for every ton of rice patty,
you'll get about 60, let's say average
60% of actually milled rice. Then you
get your rice brand and you get your
rice husk. That rice husk is a problem
for a lot of rice mills. So you go to a
lot of the rice mills the rice husk is
packed and they either set fire to it
and the few of them who have dryers will
use will burn the rice husk to dry the
rice patty there's an opportunity to
converse rice husk into MDF boards for
furniture like this even the rice straw
you can use them for furniture like this
you mill them into fine powder you add a
binding agent you compress and become
bolts like this that you can use for
construction for partitioning in like um
drywalls and all those things. So
there's an opportunity to use that. Also
the broken rice and the discolored rice,
there's an opportunity to use them for
animal feed, for rice wine, and for
other nutritional products. Ghana's
local rice market is growing, yet
misconceptions linger. What will it take
for local rice to become the preferred
choice on every table? So if we have to
meet our rice needs and be
self-sufficient on rice, that is if we
don't pivot another um commodity to take
away the dependence on rice, we need to
grow about 2 3 4 million metric tons of
patty rice which we will then mill and
get uh maybe 2 2.5 million metric tons
of actual rice. then we meet our our
rice needs to a certain extent. So rice
is very important and I think largely we
also need to accept the fact that 1
kilogram of broken rice is also the same
as 1 kilogram of um long grain rice. So
that if we educated the population to
agree that 1 kilogram of broken rice
when you eat is the same nutritional
value and is the same stomach it will go
to 1 kilogram of long grain rice is the
same nutritional value then we in in
selling our rice we can actually mix the
broken rice with the long grain rice so
that we can reduce the price per
kilogram of um rice so that people can
afford rice. What the industry does is
that once we mail rice, we take the
grade A, which is the full long grain
rice. That's where a lot of rice um
investors get their returns from. So
they price that higher and that's what
people want. Everybody wants to buy long
grain rice. So you pay more for that
long grade. The grade B sometimes is
mixed with the grade A and then the
grade C it goes to school feeding
program or for animal feeding. But once
we able to mix this in a good um
percentage, we can then not concentrate
the final retail cost of the rice on the
grid A. We can spread it among these
three so people will still get the
volumes at a better uh uh price which
will help the industry. So I think it's
something we need to do with the
industry. Ghana's agricultural potential
is vast. With your support, we can make
local rice a symbol of national pride.